not only is April the fifth great
because it's the first day you can walk
outside without a jacket but for Star
Trek fans its first contact day the day
of the initial meeting between humans
and Vulcans with Star Trek beyond
hitting cinemas in July director Justin
Lin took to Twitter to tease a picture
from the sets I'm Lucie and welcome to
your final frontier
GameSpot news update not only does the
image reveal new alien races but it
seems that there may be some famous
faces underneath the makeup Lin
accompanied the tweet with a blog post
that revealed that he had previously
worked with the two mysterious alien
actors he offered the prize of crew
t-shirts and posters to whoever
correctly guessed their identity II
wrote Here I am hanging with two of my
favorite people to ever work with I know
this would probably be a tough one since
the casting of these two actors hasn't
been announced yet and you won't find
them listed on IMDB so here's a hint
I've worked with them both before STB
the suggested names that followed the
post included Dwayne the rock Johnson
vin diesel Kim Colt Sung Kang and
communities Danny Pudi Star Trek beyond
is set for release on July 22nd 2016 so
who do you think is behind the mask let
me know in the comments below or come
find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy James
games for more on Star Trek and Beyond
make sure to keep in GameSpot